[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález es una realidad
que ya está afectando a varias regiones
del planeta que ya ha sido catalogada
como una crisis estoy hablando de la
crisis energética provocada por las
condiciones generadas por el cambio
climático y también por el aumento de la
demanda en muchas regiones los precios
por ejemplo del gas natural se han
disparado y ha hecho que se enciendan
las alarmas de cara al futuro o de cara
al invierno boreal una época en la que
hay una mayor demanda de energía para
poder iluminar y también para el uso de
la calefacción en los hogares los
gobiernos están bajo presión algunos
enfrentan apagones como en china o
también en india y en otros países como
por ejemplo en europa han mantenido o
han tenido que incrementar la demanda de
carbón para hacer frente a la situación
que se está presentando recordemos que
el carbón es la fuente de energía fósil
que más contamina el ambiente pero lo
hacen para poder hacer frente a las
necesidades que se les están presentando
veamos algunas de las cifras de consumo
el consumo de energía a nivel para el
año 2019 estuvo repartido de la
siguiente manera
combustibles fósiles es decir petróleo
carbón y gas natural representan el 80
por ciento del consumo la energía eólica
sólo el 2% mientras que la energía solar
solo alcanzó el 1 por ciento
estamos ante el comienzo de una crisis
energética a nivel mundial es esta una
muestra de la necesidad de acelerar la
diversificación de las fuentes de
energía que ayuden a contrarrestar la
demanda y a su vez también sean energías
limpias para ayudar con el cuidado del
medio ambiente este panorama la alta
demanda una producción al límite también
en algunos casos la poca capacidad de
almacenamiento nos indican que lograr
los compromisos energéticos como algunos
de los que fueron pactados en la
reciente con 26 no va a ser fácil porque
ante la crisis y la necesidad estamos
retomando los combustibles fósiles como
el carbón por ejemplo el mensaje es muy
claro hay que acelerar el cambio de la
matriz energética la crisis energética a
nivel mundial es entonces nuestro tema
de debate hoy en france 24 y para
analizar este tema hemos invitado a
andrea marín ella es directora general
de energía by fire méxico una firma
libre ha sido en inglés méxico pero el
origen español una firma consultora que
asesora en temas de compra de
electricidad ella también se encuentra
por supuesto en la capital mexicana la
ciudad de mexico
rabinovich él es ingeniero y académico
se encuentra en la ciudad de buenos
aires la capital argentina y aquí en el
estudio de france 24 está con nosotros
juan benavides él es miembro del comité
de estudios del world energy council e
investigador asociado de fedesarrollo a
los tres les doy la bienvenida a nuestro
programa pero también les recuerdo que
ustedes los televidentes pueden
participar en este debate con sus
comentarios y con sus preguntas lo
pueden hacer a través de nuestras redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook en
instagram y en twitter estamos como
france24
s les recuerdo que nuestra etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas para
tenerlas en cuenta en este debate a
través de las redes sociales comienzo
con andrea marín en la ciudad de mexico
en la capital mexicana
y partamos por la pregunta básica andrea
porque está teniendo lugar esta crisis
energética que deja digamos muy
malparada la que la reciente cumbre de
la cob 26 porque los países se están
preocupando más
por abastecerse de energía para
garantizar la energía de los ciudadanos
que las necesidades que nos está
imponiendo el cambio climático para que
bueno primero que nada hola hay muchas
gracias porque me estás en santiago yo
creo que esta es una coyuntura de causas
no necesariamente es una causa
individual sino que son varias causas
que se han juntado en un momento
histórico para ser el preámbulo a esta
crisis energética entonces cuáles son
esas causas o esas posibles causas yo
creo que la primera es a tasas de
interés bajas esto quiere decir bajo
costo del capital porque esto es fue una
reacción para la recuperación del cob y
de la mayoría de países y la mayoría de
bancos centrales esto hace que la
economía esté creciendo y se esté
gastando a tasas y niveles que no han
que no habíamos visto antes pero al
mismo tiempo venimos de por igual por la
pandemia de cadenas de suministro rotas
de cadenas de suministro que vienen con
ciertas restricciones o arrastrando
ciertas restricciones que sucedieron por
el cobijo
luego vemos otras causas como tú bien
indicas este una fuerte demanda por
atrás por migrar todos los proyectos de
generación de electricidad a energías
renovables esto que hace que la
inversión que históricamente se hacía en
proyectos de petróleo y de gas natural
vaya en picada cada vez más oímos a
fondos como blackrock o este
inversionistas institucionales que ya no
van a invertir un solo centavo en este
tipo de proyectos de infraestructura eso
que hace debieran de estar creciendo a
la misma tasa que estos proyectos de gas
y de petróleo usted se acaban las
energías renovables y creo que como tú
lo mostraste en las gráficas eso no se
ha dado estamos hablando que la energía
eólica y solar tendrían que crecer que
crecer en porcentaje dos mil quinientos
para poder abastecer la actual demanda
esos números resultan hoy pues todavía
impensables cuánto capital se debería de
invertir en esto cuánto terreno
requeriríamos y así vamos hacia allá sin
embargo no estamos allá
y luego existen otras causas que son
causas políticas este que podría ser el
tema de rusia por ejemplo no con el tema
de rusia rusia también está ejerciendo
presión por el tema rusia normalmente
abastece gran parte de la demanda de gas
natural de europa y lo que está haciendo
ahorita es mantener el gas que exporta a
europa siempre únicamente para abastecer
los contratos de largo plazo sin embargo
no está suministrando más gas natural
para este otro hueco o bueno para
abastecer toda la demanda que existe en
europa así pues lo que estamos viendo es
una presión política por parte de rusia
para qué
y construya y entre en operación cuando
que entre en operación este gas este
gasoducto sí que el tema de este
gasoducto es que llevaría atrás
directamente si andrea por favor le pido
que sea más puntual porque tengo sólo 30
minutos de programa tres invitados y
necesito al él también la palabra a
gerardo rabinovich en la ciudad de
buenos aires
vuelvo con la pregunta el punto de
partida a gerardo
complemente más lo que ha dicho ya
andrea que está causando esta crisis
energética porque estamos llegando a
este escenario tan complejo sobre todo
después de una cantidad de compromisos a
los que suscribieron los la gran mayoría
de los gobiernos a nivel internacional
para hacer una transición energética que
supuestamente ya viene en marcha pero
tal vez no está dando no se está dando
con la rapidez que necesitamos como lo
ve usted
buenas noches santiago bueno por suerte
andreas hizo una introducción muy
completa y yo trataría de sintetizar la
en tres puntos el primer punto tiene que
ver con la inercia entre la oferta y la
demanda y el
desacople producido por la pandemia en
el año pasado yo la demanda y la oferta
no pudo ir al mismo ritmo y siguió
acumulando y los precios se desplomaron
y por otro lado en la recuperación
económica este año y se hace que la
demanda crezca a una mayor velocidad
cuesta el oferta y por lo tanto hay un
fenómeno de desacople hay una inercia
por parte de la oferta en reaccionar
rápidamente a los requerimientos la
demanda en segundo lugar si
adelante gerardo puntual consumo con su
conclusión
en segundo lugar
una reacción de industria por recuperar
espacios perdidos en el 2020 tratando de
tener precios que remuneren y te
permitan recuperar la digamos perdida
sufrir año pasado y en este lugar une
una respuesta política a todas estas
digamos sensaciones por parte de los
países productores
que frente a la amenaza del cambio
climático e intentamos un juicio
erróneamente tratar de
hacer crear la francisca energética e la
culpable de el problema que se está
viviendo y por acá en el estudio de
juana de france 24 juan benavídez juan
jump tenemos básicamente un panorama de
por qué estamos en este escenario pero
lo que uno puede ver como un ciudadano
común es que los países occidentales
están teniendo como una especie de
contradicción que se están
comprometiendo
las transiciones hacer unos cambios no
se están dando tan rápido como debería
ser y al contrario el consumo se está
disparando y la demanda está
incrementándose también uno cómo
entender estos dos escenarios primero el
fenómeno que tenemos de aumento de la
demanda es un choque temporal si la
economía mundial viene creciendo por
decir algo al 3% con la pandemia bajo al
menos 6 o sea que un cambio de 9 puntos
que se estás recuperando en un año
entonces es una presión brutal sobre la
producción de todos los bienes de la
energía y ahí donde haya el potencial de
ejercicio poder de mercado como en el
gas internacional se va a ejercer para
subir los precios entonces lo veo por lo
pronto con un choque temporal de todas
formas la transición va a demorar mucho
porque hay muchos usos densos en energía
por volumen como el transporte aéreo
las calderas etcétera que van a
demorarse en llegar a la transición
hacia
tecnologías diferentes eso toma tiempo y
creo que se necesita mucha investigación
y desarrollo para lograr rentabilidades
comerciales en el uso final que es el
cuello de botella de la transición
energética no las fuentes primarios sino
los usos finales usted habla que esto va
a ser es una coyuntura eso es algo
temporal han estipulado más o menos
cuánto puede durar esta esta alta
demanda que se está presentando hasta
que llegue a normalizarse otra vez la
demanda y lo suministro tengo un
estimativo pero subjetivamente creería
que en seis meses más esto tendería a
normalizarse a esto el problema del
exceso de demanda de energía se conjuga
el problema de los containers como vemos
aquí en las gráficas etcétera hay una
serie de congestión es por que la
demanda mundial de todos los bienes y
servicios está presionada por la red el
rebote no se en muy corto tiempo
interesante ese punto andrea en la
ciudad de mexico hay mucha presión para
los gobiernos a nivel internacional
hemos visto como eeuu ha tenido que
presionar no solamente a sus productores
de combustibles a nivel interno sino
sino también a sus grandes aliados en
medio oriente para que reciban mayor
cantidad de petróleo para ellos poder
suplir la cantidad de gasolina que se
necesita en eeuu los frentes son
diversos
a que se están exponiendo aquí los
gobiernos con esta presión por parte de
los ciudadanos y la demanda que tal
parece que les queda un poco grande
satisfacer
claro pues yo creo que los gobiernos
están exponiendo un poco a ver que hay
una fuerte dependencia por ejemplo
méxico tiene una fuerte dependencia
energética de eeuu el 90 por ciento del
gas que utilizamos en el país lo traemos
de eeuu entonces pues necesitamos
acciones coordinadas un gobierno
que está en comunicación con los vecinos
del norte etcétera pero por otra parte
existe una población y ciudadanos y
usuarios de la red que constantemente
demandan electricidad más barata y más
limpia entonces estamos como frente a
esta contradicción si punto difícil y es
el punto que nos lleva a esta coyuntura
también gerardo en la ciudad de buenos
aires también vemos en europa un
escenario similar europa está demandando
grandes cantidades de gas natural en
este momento para poder suplir los
sistemas de calefacción los sistemas de
calefacción y también algo de energía
debido a que ya está entrando el
invierno allí en europa ya lo
mencionaban lo mencionaba entre a rusia
está poniendo un poco de presión en el
mercado pero vemos países por ejemplo
como que nos certifica el gasoducto del
norte stream que buscaba precisamente
sacar gas desde la ciudad de víborg en
el golfo de finlandia hasta las costas
alemanas para suministrar allí el gas y
no lo certifican cómo entender uno esa
necesidad que hay pero que el gobierno
alemán tampoco ayuda un poco para
suministrar el gas en europa
bueno esto
tiene que ver con entonces el punto que
yo mencionaba al principio y son las
consecuencias políticas de la
característica el equipo de de la
energía de los países europeos no pueden
tolerar que tierno le falte gas sin
embargo las presiones geopolíticas
trasnacionales del templo a una
dependencia mayor de rusia y por lo
tanto
digamos traba la habilitación de ese
gasoducto y
digamos
la transición energética por otro lado
en el resto del mundo también es una
digamos pulgadas entre las dos grandes
casas china y eeuu a ver quién toma
esta nueva
situación claro y seis aspectos
políticos de ética por monitor
y por este lado juan que tanto está aquí
el juego político sobre la mesa vemos la
presión de rusia que cada invierno es la
presión sobre la unión europea para
abastecerla ahora analizamos el tema de
alemania aquí que tanto es del juego
político en el juego político
internacional se transmite a través de
los canales del petróleo y del gas
ya que son el petróleo que siempre ha
sido transable el gas empieza a ser cada
vez más transable y se discute en
colombia por ejemplo la necesidad de
construir o no una segunda planta de
regasificación en el pacífico colombiano
versus estimular la producción doméstica
es la presión y la volatilidad de
precios del gas siempre hace que el
debate nunca cuaje porque porque en muy
poco tiempo se pasan bipolar mente a
opiniones contrarias entonces el
principal nicho en el cual
lo que pasa en el mundo se transmite
colombia es en el gas y el incertidumbre
abastecimiento que se tiene por lo
pronto no hay claridad sobre lo que está
pasando si se estimula o no la
producción doméstica y si se posee
importa
andrea en la ciudad de mexico como
empezar a
plantear una estrategia energética y
empezar a destrabar esta rueda
para agilizar esa transición que debemos
hacer que claramente el planeta está
pidiendo que hagamos y las condiciones
ambientales en las que estamos viviendo
exigen que hagamos una transición
llevamos ya varios años con acuerdos con
compromisos pero tal parece que la
estrategia no está funcionando desde su
óptica cómo podemos destrabar esta rueda
porque pensar que vamos a pasar de una
red primordialmente basada en
combustibles fósiles a una red
enteramente renovable en un par de años
imposible o muy posible pero aquí el
costo y creo que el costo lo estamos
viendo ahorita una crisis energética a
precios muy altos en fin creo que
estamos perdiendo la oportunidad de
reducir emisiones de efecto invernadero
gases de efecto invernadero en 50 por
ciento de manera muy rápida de qué
manera con energías de captación de co2
en plantas de generación de energías de
generación de energía en fuentes fósiles
por ejemplo que podríamos hacer toda la
energía que se produce las plantas de
generación que se producen con carbón o
que se producen con petróleo
reconvertirlas a gas natural luego
también ya existen muchas tecnologías
que permiten captar ese metano que
muchas veces se libera a la atmósfera
entonces creo que estamos queriendo
transitar de los combustibles fósiles
100% las energías limpias cuando hay un
camino de transición cuál un camino
intermedio que además nos podría ayudar
a alcanzar nuestras metas de limitar el
incremento de la temperatura del mundo a
1.5 grados
gerardo vemos que los países en esta
cumbre de 26 algunos países como india
ya pidieron nuevas fechas habían
suscrito algunos compromisos y ya han
cambiado las fechas porque no están
evolucionando tan rápido claramente para
los países industrializados países que
económicamente tienen más recursos va a
ser una transición mucho más fácil pero
qué hay de los países con pocos recursos
económicos para poder hacer estas
transiciones quien nos puede ayudar cómo
puede ayudar la comunidad internacional
para que no se queden atrás y que el
mundo entero haga una transición pareja
no unos y otros se queden atrás que es
lo que siempre nos pasa a nivel
internacional siempre hay unos que toman
ventaja
bueno esto está muy claro que los que
tienen ansiedad las energéticas
respetables
estas iones histórico donde gases esto
madero en la nota son los países
utilizados los acuerdos de parís el cual
había que incorporar o de mitigación y
de adaptación al cambio climático 100
mil millones dólares al año con los
cuales financiar acciones de los países
en desarrollo los países pobres de la
india los países pobres nuestra américa
latina para estar acciones que permitan
reemplazar los presos esta incorporación
llena no se dio hasta ahora los
resultados de la dra tampoco han dado
compromisos dientes como para que esos
fondos puedan ser puestos a disposición
de aquellos país que lo requieren y que
hoy por cuestiones de desarrollo
emitiendo más el espectro de los países
desarrollados
y digamos está esta carencia de fondos e
impide que se cumplan estos compromisos
llamados estrategias de largo plazo en
los acuerdos de parís para alcanzar
2050 2060
2.072 con emisiones de carbono ventas
iguales para éste se van aquí en el
estudio france24 le quiero preguntar por
el caso de colombia que usted lo conoce
muy bien y la región de américa latina
como estamos en este proceso de la
transición cómo está la región en
términos de adopción de energías más
limpias y renovables
cada país tiene peculiaridades que hace
que las sendas de cumplir los acuerdos
de glasgow sean muy distintos colombia
es un país que consume muy poca energía
per cápita y total evite mí muy poco co2
per cápita y total y allí la
el cuello de botella no está en la
financiación en colombia en y en muchos
países de américa latina de la
financiación hay un apetito gigantesco
por bonos verdes soberanos bonos verdes
privados etcétera y yo no veo hoy el
cuello de botella un estudio de naciones
unidades de este año habla de que es
posible que la inversión en mitigación
sea del 0.5 por ciento del pib mundial
eso es una cantidad relativamente
modesta y lograble y el cuello de
botella no está en la financiación sino
en hacer buenos proyectos que sean
rentables financieramente para los
inversionistas privados primero que todo
eso decir yo soy levemente oportunista
yo voy primero por la rentabilidad
inversionistas que en la que la remoción
de so2 entonces veo yo
en cada país diferencias grandes aquí en
colombia en particular la urgencia debe
ser la financiación de la
eficiencia energética el transporte la
electrificación del transporte masivo
urbano y la construcción y el 51 por
ciento de las emisiones de colombiano
vienen del sector de energía si no
vienen del sector de la agricultura
deforestación y cambio de uso del suelo
entonces la energía no es el culpable ni
el principal responsable de la
solución de la descarbonización cede
y andrea al inicio el programa veíamos
los porcentajes del consumo de energía
usted mencionaba la energía solar y la
energía eólica que como veíamos son
porcentajes muy bajos los costos de
estos dos tipos de energía eólica y
solar se han reducido de manera drástica
recientemente pero qué tan competitivos
son frente a los combustibles fósiles
que son mucho más competitivos que ya
están prácticamente en todos los
mercados y que es más fácil acceder a
ellos
bueno en méxico los últimos precios que
tuvimos de energía eólica y solar fueron
los precios de la segunda una de las
subastas que llevamos a cabo en el país
para comprar energía y los precios más
baratos fueron los precios de la eólica
y la solar estamos hablando que de
alrededor de 20 dólares por megawatt
ahora por este tipo de energías son
precios históricamente bajos creo que
estas energías renovables nunca habían
estado más mucho mucho más baratas que
los combustibles fósiles entonces a
nivel precio siguen siendo muy
competitivas sin embargo presentan otros
riesgos otros otros riesgos otros sobre
costos por ejemplo la intermitencia la
intermitencia sigue siendo un problema y
hay que apreciarla de alguna manera no
se sigue pagando a las centrales de
generación
de gas natural o combustibles fósiles
por servicios conexos para poder contar
con una red que pueda soportar estos
picos y bajadas en el consumo y en la
generación de electricidad
punto importante a destacar
vuelvo hago la ronda a la inversa ya le
doy la palabra a gerardo en la ciudad de
buenos aires sigo con juan aquí en el
estudio de france 24
cuando usted nos mencionaba que los
recursos están hay dinero para poder
poner en marcha algunos tipos de
proyectos de quien depende más entonces
de fomentarlo a través de los gobiernos
de américa latina o mucha más iniciativa
desde la parte privada
para que se lleven a cabo y
porque básicamente puede uno sentir que
uno no se entera que existen estos
fondos tan fácil de fácil acceso para
poder plantear proyectos si hay
gigantescos problemas de coordinación
entre oferta y demanda en colombia que
es el caso que yo más conozco los
industriales desconocen de las
ventanillas de financiación y son
adversos al riesgo a cambiar sus
tecnologías probadas con tecnologías con
fósiles les da miedo perder un poco de
confiabilidad no importa que ahorren un
poco de dinero y que sí que contribuyen
a la descarbonización ellos un riesgo de
confiabilidad entonces hay primero que
todo una gran gap entre oferta y demanda
de financiación y desinformación hay
fallas de mercado en ese lugar y en
segundo lugar hay una serie de
tecnologías que requieren un poco más de
investigación y desarrollo para llegar a
su fase ya comercial entonces los
estados deben financiar los fondos para
subsidiar estas tecnologías están al
borde de la de la comercialidad
invertir en investigación y desarrollo
para
transformar lo que se llama la curva de
abatimiento de coste costo de
abatimiento del carbón bajarla hacerla
más económica y desplazarla para que
haya más cubrimiento si con eso lo
hacemos el estado podrá ayudar
contribuir notoriamente a que el sector
privado se pueda mover se requieren
vehículos de inversión por ejemplo
singapur hizo un fondo de eficiencia
energética en vez de que cada sector por
su lado el saludo agricultura hiciera un
fondo para su respectivo sector entonces
se requieren vehículos para reducir
costos de transacción y reducir los
gastos entre oferta y demanda y que el
estado
en investigación y desarrollo así
estamos la comunicación con gerardo en
la ciudad de buenos aires gerardo hemos
visto a lo largo de estos años que si
hay una región o un país
o si un grupo de países abanderados para
esta transición energética para evitar
este tipo de crisis que estamos viviendo
en este momento es la unión europea es
la gran región que es abanderada en
muchos de los proyectos pero en este
momento el consumo de carbono está
disparado en europa precisamente por la
demanda que tiene en el consumo de gas
también esto que nos dice que europa no
está tan adelantada como pensábamos en
materia de transición de hacia energías
más limpias que es lo que ven ustedes
te entiendo europa martes no como decía
al tipo que ordena vides es un fenómeno
coyuntural
un desacato y demanda causado por el
derrumbe económico la pandemia pero para
tiene políticas energías renovables y la
eficiencia energética
políticas de dirección de emisiones de
gas formas de troy de carbono que
américa latina debería alguna medida y
ello que sea bueno comprar tal y además
digamos buscar el saldo económico y
financiero de la unión europea para en
condiciones de mercado
era captar su
financiamiento
abundante que permita esta tablet tarea
que hemos tiene nuestra generación es la
de eliminar el humo de combustibles
fósiles a un plazo relativamente corto
para asegurar la supervivencia
andrew a nivel económico esto resulta
como una especie de círculo vicioso
porque vemos que esta alta demanda
también está provocando un aumento en
los precios las personas están teniendo
que pagar más por la energía que está
consumiendo y esto también está
afectando la inflación de la mayoría de
los países están enfrentando precios más
altos que ya no pueden acceder tan
fácilmente a diferentes objetos estamos
próximos a navidad la gente va a tener
que pagar más por la energía que comprar
reguló de regalos y fomentar el consumo
que va a reactivar la economía de los
países después de la pandemia es un
círculo vicioso hay forma de hacer una
especie de balance sobre esto
creo que lo dijiste bien es un círculo
vicioso
efectivamente la crisis energética lo
que está haciendo es está incrementando
la inflación sobre todo en industrias
que son no solamente en las casas y en
los hogares como lo menciona sino
también en muchas industrias sobre todo
aquellas que son intensivas en
electricidad por ejemplo el aluminio
está en precios que nunca en 13 años es
el precio más alto que se había visto y
esto va afectando y va afectando yo creo
que le diste al clavo al decidir cómo
buscamos ese balance no un balance entre
queremos reactivar la economía pero al
mismo tiempo no queremos activarla tanto
que después no la podemos parar y los
precios sean sean tremendos entonces
creo que es buscar ese punto medio yo
creo que como consumidores como
industrias buscar ese punto de balance
entre sí que la indú que toda la
industria sea rentable y se recupere del
cob y sin embargo buscar todavía ese
equilibrio con
con el medio ambiente no estamos viendo
que los principios de ley y cada vez son
más importantes yo diría yo que esto
debería de tener la coordinación de
todos los países y de todas las
industrias para poder llegar a ese punto
de equilibrio sin embargo resulta muy
muy vago y resulta casi casi como un
como un sueño y un buen deseo sí cuál es
ese punto no lo sé
la opinión de andrés de la ciudad de
mexico quiero conocer su opinión juan
aquí en el estudio de france 24 se puede
alcanzar ese balance para evitar que
este círculo vicioso nos consuma no no
hay no se puede hacer el balance hay que
esperar a que pase entonces esos son
ciclos de que sube el precio baja el
consumo
empieza unas fluctuaciones y
eventualmente desaparece entonces es
difícil difícil manejar la difícil
gestionarla y no tengo una solución
tampoco dinero que tanto puede aguantar
una sociedad viniendo del confinamiento
de la pandemia de ccoo y 19 es a la
pregunta difícil de responder ahí que
tanto pueden aguantar los países este
tipo de situaciones como lo ve usted
pues yo yo yo creo que los países pueden
aguantar en mi subjetividad seis meses
más de inflación es de este estilo y
después vendrán
seguramente algunas decisiones
acordadas entre los agentes que pueden
manejar los precios etcétera para que no
se les vaya en contra totalmente de la
afición gerardo creo que quería decir
algo al respecto adelante y ya estamos
entrando a la recta final del programa
para comenzar con las conclusiones
rápidamente al respecto según ya todo
agregaría y hay
en la década de los 70
del petróleo implicará primero 4
por lo demás es decir pasto de dos
dólares las prendas
y el mundo reaccionó como sustituyendo
la energía cara y
apareciendo nuevas fuentes de
abastecimiento
y aplicando la ciencia energía claro
como ya se ha dicho siempre la serbia
está la oportunidad es tu perdón gerardo
que lo que es lo que lo interrumpa pero
ya debo llegar a las conclusiones ya se
me acaba el tiempo del programa
gerardo entonces me mantengo con usted
ya que estamos en contacto rápidamente
sus conclusiones que va a venir
escenarios a futuro de lo que podemos
ver en el mundo en esta crisis
energética
bueno todo indica que la tendencia es a
más energías renovables más ética y
menos combustible fósil más tecnología
aplicadas pero energéticos y
requerimientos de apoyo técnico
financiero y económico de los países
desarrollados andrew a 30 segundos su
conclusión en ciudad de méxico
creo que las conclusiones son esta es
una crisis temporal y creo que es una
crisis muy parecida a todas las que
vivimos en los inviernos sin embargo
exacerbada por condiciones particulares
de este año este último año y esperemos
que este invierno no sea tan fuerte en
el hemisferio norte hwan la conclusión
20 segundos
pero debería exceso de financiación con
carga negativa es decir plaza parqueada
que todavía tiene proyectos
suficientemente bien estructurados para
la mitigación bueno pues se tiene la
opinión de nuestros tres invitados en
ciudad de méxico en buenos aires- y aquí
en el estudio de france 24 les agradezco
por haber estado con nosotros y ustedes
pueden seguir haciendo todos sus
comentarios y preguntas
a través de las redes sociales los
invito para que sigan participando allí
de este debate siga con la programación
de france 24
[Música]